hello
in this video
i'm going to talk about insulin
mechanism of action
so as you can see
here
after taking a
lunch
full of carbohydrate
our blood glucose level
our blood glucose level will increase
so when we take food the food
goes into the
intestine
and inside the intestine it would be
converted
into the smaller forms so the starch it
would be broken down into glucose and
glucose will have to get inside the
bloodstream and it will
be spread around the body so what will
happen in the
cell of intestinal
lumen
there are sodium dependent glucose
transporters also known as sglt
so it will take sodium ion inside
as well as
glucose
so glucose will enter through the
apical surface with the help of sglt
into the
luminal cells
and there we have
gluten the glucose transporters so
glucose transporter will take in glucose
and glucose will enter into the
bloodstream that means here represented
as a capillary
here glucose will enter into the clapite
capillary
and would be spread around the body
so what we now have the blood glucose
level is pretty high
say for instance
now this glucose keeps circulating and
get into the skeletal muscle
so now
what will happen to the happen to the
glucose we will see
so here is a cell
so this is a skeletal muscle cell
at the meantime when blood glucose level
increases
body also sense that blood glucose is
pretty high so body will secrete insulin
from the pancreas and this insulin will
come here and bind to the insulin
receptor
on the surface of the
skeletal muscle cell
so the insulin binds to the receptor
tyrosine kinase
or also pronounced as rtk
now the insulin
will do stuffs
inside the cell
so that
a preformed vesicles
which contain glute4 that means the
glucose transporter can dock in
so insulin binding ultimately triggers
glute for physical docking to the
membrane site
so once the glute for
more glute for
vesicles
dock to the membrane
more the number of
the glute for vesicles
get onto the surface of the cell
membrane
now we will see
the insulin
when binds to the rtk
it will triggers a conformational change
and that will lead to
the tyrosine kinase activity of its
cytosolic domain
and the tyrosine residues get
phosphorylated here you can see the
tyrosine residues get phosphorylated and
with this tyrosine residue another
kinase can bind
this kinase is known as pi3 kinase or
pi3k
so phosphatidyl inositol three kinase
either it could directly dock to the
phosphodius and residue or it can doc
via the insulin receptor substrate or
irs
so once pi3 kinase bind
and activated
pi3 kinase would convert pip2 to 3
actually pi3 kinase phosphorylated sp2
to pip 3
and this pit 3
which is phosphatidyl inositol 3 4 5
tris phosphate
activates akt or also known as protein
kinase b actually it was found in act 8
retrovirus and hence the name
so this act or pkb
will go to the vesicles and it can
convert rap gdp to gtp rap
in
gtp bound form is active and what happen
in the normal state
the adapter proteins
of this vesicle are
inhibited by a cap protein
so what happens this pkb actually
phosphorylates this cap
and now the caps falls off when the caps
fall off
these vesicles could be loaded onto the
kinase in motors these kinetic motors
are trucks they will carry the vesicle
to their
desired destination here in the membrane
so these vesicles loaded onto the
kinesin will move on the microtubules so
the microtubules are the highways and
ultimately the glute4 vesicles will fuse
into the membrane
and allowing more and more glucose
uptake by this muscle cell and the
muscle cell can utilize this glucose for
energy purpose you remember the
glycolysis
and this signaling is pretty important
to understand diabetes so in type 1
diabetes
insulin level is pretty low so when
insulin level is low
this signaling doesn't take
doesn't take place
and if take place it's pretty
inefficient so what happens
we don't have much this glute for basic
glute for transporters on the membrane
however in the type 2 diabetes insulin
is okay insulin is formed but the
receptor and the insulin interaction
is not sensitive so insulin can bind to
the receptor
but
doesn't trigger the cascade of reactions
or what happened in the type 2 diabetes
any of these steps of this total signal
transduction cascade could be faulty as
a result
these glute 4 vesicles would not
fuse to the membrane and it will not
allow
glucose to enter the cell
so another interesting aspect is this
glute for transporters
glut4 are exclusively found in skeletal
muscle whereas glute 1 is found in rbc
glute tree in brain glute true in liver
for instance in liver when glucose
needed to be converted into glycogen
so liver will uptake with glut2
transporter
not to buy glute4 and in brain so brain
food is actually glucose so brain
exclusively utilize glucose for energy
so blade brain need to take up glucose
by glute tree
if much of these transporter are not in
the membrane so what will happen
even if glucose is present in the
peripheral region the cell cannot uptake
glucose and cannot utilize so that
happens into the diabetes where glucose
is present into the peripheral
area of the cells but the cells cannot
utilize glucose as a result the blood
glucose level
is pretty high
and that would lead to
some pathological conditions
hope you enjoyed the video thank you